I don't personally believe right but
it's like that doesn't mean that we
can't live the same way hey there i'm
erica Campbell I'm a singer a songwriter
I'm a mom a wife and all-around cool
chick so today I'm sitting down with
people from different ends of the faith
spectrum just gonna have a healthy
conversation can't wait to get into it
I'm really excited
my name is Josh and I am a former
Christian hi I'm Emily and I identify as
an atheist my name is Nina and I
identify as agnostic I was raised in a
very strict Mormon household I was the
very first one in my family to leave the
church
I have been happy non-believer ever
since I guess technically I was raised
in the Catholic faith kind of by default
we went to church sometimes on Christmas
usually like weddings or funerals
something like that I grew up lightly
Hindu we're like cults really Hindu but
I kind of came to the conclusion that
like whether or not there is a God or
there isn't a god like it has no bearing
on like how I live my life I don't think
she'll be able to in any way convert me
suddenly back I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't nervous like I hope I don't say
anything to offend her hey hey there I'm
Josh I'm Erica I'm Emily Erica nice to
meet you to meet you too nice to meet
you Vanina yes I mean nice to meet you
so I'm a Christian how would you
identify atheist yes non-believer so do
you believe that like there's there's no
bad or there's something out there and
you don't know what it did nothing
nothing I identify as Nate yes if like
agnosticism and atheism it's like a
spectrum I'm like somewhere in it I
think that when we die it's lights out
and that's the blissful end to all of it
emily is so let me ask you a question
what do you believe exists beyond the
universe like the area where our minds
kind of exist not the human not the
tangible I don't think that that exists
either you don't I don't I think that
everything that exists is what exists
right here right now in this moment in
your body I was raised in the Catholic
community I just remember the first
thing we talked about was Adam and Eve
I just remember being like that's just
like a little story it culturally were
him though personally for me it felt
like a lot of these a lot of the stories
of it or they're just like stories
there's a lot of like believable with
multiple arms and like angels are blue I
don't which is like not real so I was
raised Mormon my mom helped run the
Relief Society my dad was a bishop for a
long time grandpa was a bishop I was the
very first member of my family to walk
away from it all
and it was not well at first I grew up
similar to you but mine was a
Pentecostal church called the Church of
God in Christ and my father was a
preacher my mom was over the choir but
there was a lot of things that didn't
always make sense to me like why we were
so poor everything supposed to work out
right you know but the same way I
wouldn't doubt love because people have
gotten love and that's kind of how I
feel about God and I think it's very
reassuring to me that after this is over
there's something greater so most people
who don't believe there was some you
know traumatic Church experience or some
long line of this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense
okay y'all don't make sense so maybe he
doesn't make sense
I do find fault with what Catholicism in
general if we're not really like
practicing so we weren't like praying or
like studying or anything and so I just
kind of like fell away from that as like
as a religion I got kicked out of Sunday
school because I was arguing with the
teacher about the age of the earth in
six days 6,000 years and like but
dinosaurs I grew up in a church where
secular music was a saying everybody's
the devil you know you can't interact
you know it's gonna infiltrate you and
my mom her favorite saying growing up
was that the devil gets to in little
ways yes like the first time I wanted a
mohawk at nine years old she was like
devil gets to you through your hair yeah
I got really lucky and I have like great
parents and you know they're like you
know be kind be a good person like help
each other out
so I feel like my moral compass is good
I hope so I'm working on it the core of
Mormon belief is the Holy Bible the King
James Version specifically every time I
read something what I saw was a twist
for human game and all the same stories
and had I had the very same questions
um and what I feel like you know what I
know the Bible is it is all an example
of how crazy and chaotic our world is if
you believed in God what would that look
like to you
I feel like if there was a God I think
it would be something that kind of
unimaginable that I couldn't like
processes they came would be do you
believe in life after you know I I don't
know before I was like I don't know
maybe like roll energy like what
happened the summer that like nobody
knows and that's the crazy thing right
and but very recently actually my twin
brother passed away this summer and so
I've been thank you but I've been you
know like searching for him and I've
been like trying to be kind of like open
like if you know if it is like a thing
like please freaking talk to me you know
what I mean like I just I haven't I
haven't felt it never felt him I haven't
seen him yeah and so that kind of for me
was like okay like he's just yeah he's
just dead and that's you know something
that I'm just kind of like okay like I'm
just I'm just never gonna see him again
he's still you know with me every day
and I think about him every single day
but it's like I just you know I was I
was open for it I I still am what if
something were to happen or whatever but
like you know me thinking about him
every day and remembering him and
everything that I do it's like I feel
like that for me is like enough you know
every time I look at any form of
organized religion the only thing I see
is division more wars have been fought
over religion than anything else yeah
whereas when I look at a world with no
religion you suddenly everyone has to
own up to just what they are and who
they are they can no longer hide behind
say well I I won't bake a cake for these
gay couple because my religion says that
I don't have to you can't hide behind
that there's always gonna be conflict in
religion because religion is man-made
and all you see these movies in always a
devil on one shoulder in it
I really think that's real I think
there's always a battle for the best of
us and the worst of us if there was one
question of God that you can ask if you
believed in God what would you ask
that's a really hard thing is about you
and that's what I does you what makes
you happy why I'm feel so small and like
the concept of a god it feels so big
like I said yeah and I feel so small and
it seems impossible to me that anything
that oversees like our whole world or a
whole universe would have time for me I
think that there's still a lot of
questions there you know them from what
you've said still a lot of questions and
I think that's the best way to be like
I'm always asked why the wise are the
wise why do I feel this way why don't I
believe could I believe again right you
know what could cause me to believe
again because clearly there's something
that caused me not to believe if I told
you that I would pray for you what would
you ask me to pray for that's a great
question probably not for me but for
like my family I think yeah yeah just
for them to be like well and good and
happy yeah from my perspective
everything you said you can do without
any religion and it's completely freeing
for me the most free I ever felt was the
day I walked away and said I don't have
to believe in any of this stuff anymore
cuz to me God religion all of it it's
completely superfluous to human
existence you don't need it you can live
a happy productive good charitable life
without it I believe in you know if
there's a good there has to be a bad you
know we can't always explain some of the
complexities and craziness of this world
but I think God brings gravity to it all
to the question I love hearing what you
have to say I don't think I necessarily
agree with all of it
I believe that God knows you he knows
your name he knows how many hairs on
your head
beautiful hair by the way that's a
purchase mind nevertheless I think he
knows everything about you and what's to
get wants to know more this has been
such a great conversation and there's
such a warm like I feel really like
comfortable here yeah it just this has
been really great
something amazing talking about right
talking to you Emily I will be praying
for you thank you absolutely so much
[Music]